there are so many places in this series
that we hear about but never see lands
like Londo with its Hollow civilization
and towers that are said to resemble the
thorns of the mauryan blade or places
like Karthus of the sands with its
warlike culture and giant sand worms
beneath dunes if only we could travel to
the country of Catarina where the people
are drunk and lively or the city of Vinh
time a place of magic and subterfuge
then there are the broken lands places
with only a trace of their former glory
places like izalith whose unique
architecture is mostly in ruins now or
places like hade whose architecture is
barely seen at all only hinted at by
what Peaks above the waves at least the
water here isn't a swamp like the one
that's overtaken Ferren or a threat like
the waters that doomed New Londo if we
could restore these places to their
former glory I bet even the undead burg
could surprise you so how about we do
just that this video and this topic is
the inspiration for the third art
competition on this channel one way you
have to render or restore these lands
for your chance at one thousand seven
hundred and fifty US dollars I'll go
into more detail on the competition at
the end of the video but for now listen
carefully as even if you're not an
artist I'm gonna tell you everything we
know about these lands and the people
who inhabit them we begin with the
ruined land of astora so weapons from
astora commonly scale with faith and
luck both of which are stats that define
humankind in a major way in turn these
weapons belong to chivalrous Knights who
are commonly found sporting the famous
elite Knight armor with its fire warding
symbols on it that mark a senior night
of astora think of the people from this
place solare Oscar honoree these are all
Knights that you're glad to meet on your
adventure for their brave and kind
unfortunately these Souls from astora
are commonly doomed
which makes their courage burn all the
brighter even prints regard whose tragic
tales are hinted at but never told
likely fights you because he was
hallowed and lost his story and their
land to shares this doomed fate ruined
astora
it is cold and while we don't know how
it fell into ruin one of the creatures
that nearly doomed it was called the
evil eye which was a foul spirit that
once ravaged astora getting stronger
with every kill luckily it was defeated
by the sword of one most noble these
things should help you to form the
visual imagery for this place so what do
you imagine I kind of see a shining
sword in a ruined Kingdom filled with
noble Souls that believe in fate and
prophecy who fight on to the bitter end
next we have the Orthodox land of Thurl
and the original capital of the way of
white nowhere else we find a more deeply
tired church and state a land of great
Royals priests bishops and judges rings
and armor from this place often enhance
your ability to cast and remember
miracles but back in Thurl and these
items were primarily given to reward and
to represent your rank within the
church's hierarchy and the Thurl and
talisman is a good example of this it's
only granted to high-ranking Thurl and
clerics yet ironically it does not scale
with faith and it actually allows you to
perform powerful miracles with
relatively little faith it's a good
reflection upon the man who wields it as
well Petrus a self-described wolf in
sheep's clothing who has little problem
killing in cold blood
despite his faith and his rank thorough
lands visual identity is that of a white
City faithful to all father Lloyd and to
Lord Gwyn's
age of fire however the closer look
reveals this regime that excels in
dividing mankind controlling the masses
and persecuting the under
next is a land so different to Thurl and
that they actually went to war with them
for a time next is vinhai' home of the
famed dragon school which rules the
nation from the shadows via its deadly
agents who are well versed in
surreptitious sorceries so for reference
you looked magics like hush which masks
the sounds of the user while the city is
effectively controlled by the Dragons
school magic infuses all of its
professions look to their swordsman who
augment their weapons and shields with
magical strength look to its Smiths who
toil away at magic embers and of course
look to its sorcerers the most famous of
whom is big head Logan who's soul Spears
was said to be on par with the lightning
bolts of Lord Gwyn himself Vin Holmes
visual identity is this mirror of
intelligence and cunning a city
dedicated to knowledge and learning even
if it is acquired through less than
savory means another land of sorcery is
Melfi er though it's rarely spoken off
online I don't even think I've said the
name on this channel so once there was
this paranoid King who was struggling to
deal with the great numbers of the
accursed so in his desperation he
commanded this contorted century to
deliver those with no cells to a faraway
land to make certain that they would
never be heard from again the hardy
survivors made ground in a southern land
called Melfi ER where they began to
impart their knowledge of sorcery to its
people as a result
proud school arose there dedicated to
studying sorcery pyromancy and even the
stars its astrologists believe that
magical powers can be obtained during
special moments of heavenly alignment
and
it's sorcerers have this great sense of
pride in the knowledge that they
retained from the old days so much so
that it actually blinds them to the
truth Mel views visual identity should
probably aligned with the ragged attire
of Rosabeth and Karelian as well as with
the astrologist set and all of the
instruments that they would have used
there should be enough to accurately
represent their proud but destitute
origins another land with great meaning
in the clothes that they wear is the
ancient land of Xena birthplace of the
infamous dominum Domino explores the
world and he crops up in all of these
unlikely places to engage in trade with
you sporting this wide selection of
really rare goods
however the rarest Goods he wears
himself despite their gaudy appearance
because Domhnall dons the armor of the
glorious the gauntlets of the Vanquisher
the boots of the Explorer and the helm
of the Y's so Xena's visual identity can
only really be based upon this man its
land with this ancient mysterious
history and it's one that likely values
trade and adventure just as highly as
Donal himself an equally eccentric land
in Dark Souls 2 is Lanna fear a country
far to the south of sharing lake which
has preserved its customs due to a
long-standing policy of isolationism so
two pieces of attire really define this
place first there's the travelling
merchants set with its blue headpiece
that increases item discovery and also
its Eagle spaulder that symbolizes
wealth so despite this policy of
isolationism there's also a theme here
of exploration and trading because this
is the set that's worn by the Explorer
class honestly these themes overlap
almost entirely with Xena but one
addition is that there's this visitor
that comes from LAN affair called Dogo
who wears a blue monocled hat which is
also worn by a dark spirit that fights
you outside of drangleic
so this man who is likely dirgo was a
famous expert Bowman and along with his
brother-in-law they defended their
homeland from aggressors there's not
much visually to go on here but that
does make it more of an open slate and
they feel free to represent the
characters in your artwork as well
another place that's perpetually
defending itself from aggressors is
mirror surrounded on all sides by
violent neighbors it's for this reason
that a unique culture of knights has
developed men and women well-versed in
combat of all sorts be it
holy defenses like great magic barrier
assassinations by shadow Knights in the
cover of darkness or just the standard
chivalry that's embodied by Knights like
Lucas he'll who fight with great swords
that are wielded with this rare
technique when I think about a visual
for mirror I think about all of its
warriors busy fighting or training and
even children playing at being Knights
in the streets there's also a holy pool
that is mentioned in the holy water own
description because apparently Mira has
this well-protected spring that produces
holy water and it's used to heal allies
and scold the undead though apparently
it's really difficult to find in these
war filled times on the flip side you
have for OSA a country of assailants in
contrast to the assailed of mirror for
OSA has always made war with its
neighbors producing a ton of fine
warriors and also dangerous explosives
as a result but even paying reverence to
their war god Ferran couldn't stop these
endless wars from ultimately imploding
their nation famous in fur OSA was Venga
a ferocious sell sword who was unmatched
in strength alongside him were the
frozen lion Knights who wore heavy armor
and were feared for their two-handed
sword play though even they kept vengo
at arm's length
there was also shield listless ioan who
retired from the battlefield in search
of a legendary dragon
to test his mettle against and lastly
there was also the north waters who were
sages who earned their title only after
they finished journeys of great hardship
after the collapse of their country
their sages their citizens and all of
their warriors scattered going on to
fight in other lands instead in the end
the most renowned of them was said to be
the ivory king of eleum loyce who was
allegedly one of the highest-ranking
Knights in his homeland of Feroze lot of
armor sets and characteristics to draw
from here so how would you depict this
country of warriors yet another merchant
town in Dark Souls 2 is Volgin in the
West it's famous for its merchants so
say clan and Moreland and it's
competitive to the point where only
those with talent and connections can
succeed there's a cleric class and a
high priest here and a familiar covenant
has also been rapidly rising in power
within the city the domestic warriors of
volgin are said to be infamously timid
which explains why the blue sentinels
have a presence in this place because
blue sentinels fight on behalf of others
for the rich elite class the 1% there is
another option and the falconers an
expensive mercenary band that serve as
well-paid bodyguards for the affluent
elite and the game goes out of its way
to tell you that they do deserve to be
well paid the wealthiest merchant of all
in volgen is a man called Fiorenza who
apparently spent himself into ruined by
buying and crafting all manner of rare
trinkets things like the Avalon which he
read about in an old book for a place
far more laid-back imagine Katarina
according to their jubilant starting
race it's people have characteristically
large eyes and mouths and a spitting
image of their country a land filled
with alcohol and rejoicing their Knights
are proud and surprisingly capable
despite looking like giant
onions although they commonly ridiculed
for that fact if you face them in battle
you may find yourself outclassed for the
convex curved surface of their armor is
highly effective at warding off physical
attacks Catarina is an Outland region
it's a land of faith but it is also
split off from the way of white which
means that they've come up with their
own miracles like amid force which is a
branching spell of force and if you want
the antithesis of Catarina imagine
kareem a land ruled by depraved lords
who mutter shady curses under the
ominous watch of Velka the goddess of
sin and kayfa the goddess of Tears or
perhaps these two women are one in the
same like catarina religion holds sway
here although its people are really grim
and selfish and all of their talismans
have an affinity for dark magic
despite things being anathema to the
church famous individuals from Korea are
said to sport this gloomy countenance
people like Law Trek or Aegon and
another character from here is the Earl
a store who turned people he didn't
impale into stones and once these living
people were stones they could be used to
draw curses out from the living a clue
to carry visual identity can sort of be
found in mourns great hammer which is
decorated by a ward of Kareem temple and
looks like it could be a part of the
Gothic architecture of the place if you
think there's not enough swamps in the
Dark Souls series I'm gonna depict
another one then maybe you can consider
drawing the Great Swamp which is home to
pyromancers shamans and heretics who
wish to become one with nature and to
carry on the old ways these people were
driven out of the main city into the
hinterlands which is a word that
commonly refers to
underdeveloped a rural area somewhere
that's outside of the city and is
commonly found behind a coast or on the
shoreline of a river there's this trend
in desert countries in Dark Souls where
they all have an affinity for pyromancy
places like Karthus for example have
warriors who swept across countless
nations like a Desert Storm with their
weapons imbued with fire conquering and
looting as they went this conquering
spirit it infused their culture and it
inspired this inclination towards
victory no matter the cost
just so unethical Perriman seas were
also born in this land spells like acid
surge which corrode weapons and armor
and even the black flame pyromancies of
high lord wall neo who was the conqueror
who sentenced countless souls to
gruesome deaths although eventually his
own kingdom was relegated to the
catacombs a long time ago I commissioned
this piece this Karthus thumbnail from
an incredible artist and it should serve
as a good benchmark for what this art
competition can achieve although it is
missing one thing the giant Karthus
sandworms monsters that right beneath
the dinners giant wildlife like
pyromancy seems to be a trend in these
designations because in you go home to
the enchanting desert sorceresses we
hear of giant ants whose corrosive acid
is stored and then thrown in urns giant
ant hills are created by these corrosive
ants and they said to line the horizon
of this desert land which is really good
visual imagery and while and larvae are
considered a delicacy to these people he
who recklessly enters an anthill will
surely have their flesh melted to the
bone the founder of Hugo was all
a man with legendary armor that is said
to be invisible to a coward's eye you
can't see it can you
also important are the deserts
Sorceress's I mentioned who catch foes
off-guard with their enchanting looks
and are frequently found in poisoned
lands these characters are actually the
epitome of a desert land because their
pyromancers were always found in either
a desert or a swampland next we delve
into all mentions of the Far East with
people whose faces are said to be the
village of a true dragon they have this
exquisitely crafted armor and apparently
it defends well from slashing attacks as
katanas are predictably
the weapon of choice for many people
here another weapon that's mentioned is
the Oni Slayer great boat with large
arrows that are used to destroy giant
horned Oni Oni translates to demon but
these are never seen in game and as with
most places the Far East also has its
share of assassins whose shadow set
aligns with that of a shinobi it's a
place that shouldn't be too hard to
imagine as the tropes and the
stereotypes from the Far East are pretty
predictable another easy place to
envision should belonged or whose towers
are said to resemble the branching
blades and thorns of the mauryan blade
here lifeless aged and decrepit hollows
subscribe to the gospel of the black
church whose three leaders preach
salvation for them and suffering to the
living it's a land of deceit and spite
and it's inspired by the serpent calf
the people are desperate for their own
age ruled by their own Lord I would love
to see what a functioning hollow society
might look like since Halloween is not
seen here with the same disgust as it is
in other lands attire to go off of is
that of the pale shade who invades and
kills in the name of the sable Church
there's also the black set of the
founders of Londo
and of course the rags of a hollow who
does not care for a body lost to the
curse there's one land in Dark Souls one
that could not stand up to the undead
curse and that was Boulder which
collapsed under the weights of too many
Undead it's Knights are found in the
early stages of Lordran and their
evidence of a desperate raid against
this land of the Lord's which was
presumably some effort by Balder to undo
the curse that doomed their homeland
Balder was ruled by its famed night king
a man of steel named Rendell who was
said to have faced down a giant Drake
and slashed it to pieces all by himself
just so his ring of steel protection is
often found in places with dragons and
also serpents and if you wished to
depict this place or its King keep the
undead outbreak and the legends of its
King in mind
and finally there's Courland a place
known for its transposed wonders before
if you have a transposing kill then
you're able to convert powerful souls
into special items however this is
apparently a forbidden part and Colin's
forbidden obsession with souls likely
attracted this monster that's known only
as the soul feeder it's this vile
creature that insatiably absorbed Souls
to feed its own power and when it's
accursed corpse was burned it left the
air permanently stained and we have no
idea what this creature once looked like
Colin's only known member is Lilith a
Lord of cinder exiled from his homeland
that marks every land that's not seen
in-game but there are so many more that
you could envision especially if you
look to the areas that have been broken
or decayed beyond recognition places
like the undead burg that does have
evidence of everyday life lost within
its abandoned households the undead
settlement that would have once been
open to caravans and trade across the
great bridge there's an Orlando
where
gods would have gone about their
day-to-day lives with human followers to
serve at their every desire or heeds
tower of flame which may have been
similar to an Orlando before it was lost
beneath the waves imagine Allah seal
with forests illuminated by wondrous
golden sorceries and a city with humans
instead of monsters or olaphis before it
was turned into the last best deal by a
fearful King how incredible would the
unique architecture of izalith have
looked if it wasn't so ruined we may
have found God's demons and men here
living in harmony and controlling the
chaos or maybe before the chaos it was
more like the architecture of
Mesoamerica but this was the same chaos
that brought la employes to a halt
necessitating its transformation into
this frozen wasteland to keep it in
check
there's lauric before the anarchy as the
profaned capital before it was consumed
by fire and before it was profaned what
if New Londo wasn't drowned and could be
seen housing a civilization of men and
the same could apply to the iron cape
before it was drowned in magma or maybe
even Shova if sin
the dragon hadn't spewed his poison over
the city so if you're an artist
interested in competing or and this is
important if you're somebody with a
great idea who really knows the law who
wants to Commission an artist for this
competition this part is for you the
goal of this competition is to depict Al
and its cities its people or its culture
in a way that the game describes or
implies but does not show so choose a
place from the video listen well to the
details of their culture and the
character traits of those that live
within that place and extrapolate those
things to a visual medium I don't mind
if you submit multiple images as long as
you feel like every one of them is
adding something to the submission and
remember I didn't mention every single
thing about every single land here feel
free to do your own research whether
that's from my past videos or not and
remember to look up the sources present
at the bottom of the screen for each
area for additional information the
previous two art competitions also act
as great examples of what kind of art
makes it into the top ten and what kind
of criteria I might be looking for here
so it's a good idea to watch those as
well once your submission is complete
send it to dark souls art challenge at
gmail.com preferably attached as a PNG
file for easy preview make sure to tell
me a little bit about what land you're
depicting and tell us a little bit about
your piece as well please also include a
paypal address and a link to your
portfolio if you have one just in case
you win the prize money will be split as
shown on screen with portfolio shoutouts
for the top few entries your submissions
must be sent in by the end of March
though exceptions will apply in rare
cases especially if you just want to
tweak your entry in some minor way if
you have any other questions don't email
them to me instead head over to my
discord linked in the description and
here you'll find a frequently asked
questions channel and if there's no
answer there you can ask your question
in the art competition channel if it
hasn't been asked before thank you as
always for competing your entries bring
everyone so much joy and to bring me so
much joy because they're totally worth
all the prize money that I choose to
invest in them a special thank you to
Loki for helping me hammer out the
script for this video he posts a lot of
neat little things about souls law on
Twitter at Loki underscore D s who knows
maybe they'll even help you brainstorm
for the contest he's definitely someone
to keep an eye on I really look forward
to what you guys come up with good luck